something that I do want to say real
quick is that I love this game as much
as sometimes in my commentary it may
seem like I am criticizing every little
thing and don't like it so far I really
really love this game and it sure it
doesn't help that i am actually creating
a list of complaints about suggestions
that I have for the video for the game
which sounds pretty negative but i love
this game in general so far and it's
really hard for me to even create a list
of what i think this game does rights
and what is amazing about it i don't
think i could even make a video about
that but in general i just love it i
just want to basically find some of the
things that might be improved on I mean
it's amazing to have early access to a
game but the developers did actually say
that they would like to maybe even have
some feedback on what could be better
and it's honestly one of the biggest
things which also helps towards making
the weekly updates if even I got
interaction and for example doing
streams in which the people on the
stream get asked the question of what
sort of new rides or cars they wanna
have and it's stuff like that that I
think really make this game as great as
it is but that's really just my personal
opinion it's there's something that I'm
going to get out there real quick so
that i can probably criticize this game
to death and talk [ __ ] all over it and
complain about it all the time just keep
in mind that in general i will still
love this game and that's pretty much it
also i do have to say it is currently
the 15th of december and hopefully this
video actually gets uploaded in the
fifteenth of december as well which
would be a miracle for me since usually
they get uploaded a couple of days after
i do my commentary but yesterday
actually a new updates to the game came
out which if i do release this video
today it's going to be very relevant and
it's update 75 which it was quite a
small updates but i'm really happy about
it anyway they actually added more
changes to the color tool so not only
can we actually save our colors right
now but we can even pick colors from
buildings
really I would say two of the tools
which you see in many of the fit arm
what is it all image editing that's the
way I was looking for tools that you
have on computers like two of the almost
most important tools are being able to
pick colors and being able to recall a
certain things are now in the game as
well so you can simply click whatever
type of scenery you want to have their
caller from to get a collar back that
you somehow may be lost by forgetting to
save it and you can instantly recolor
stuff which is going to make it a lot
easier to make streets and scenery in
general look the way that you once i'm
really happy about that other than that
there is stuff like some new rain which
is still to be worked on it a little bit
heavy and finally the drowning animation
is in the game so one of the things
which some people probably looked
forward to a lot is actually right here
right now that's pretty cool but I'm
yeah I'm really really happy about the
color towards one of the things which i
did have on my complaint lists so that's
something I can scrub out of there
although it's still quite extensive but
I it's certainly gonna get some use this
this footage as well as the footage from
episode 8 is still a little bit old but
from episode 9 onward I am on alpha 5 so
though we won't be seeing the new color
pick tool the new scenery and new rides
and things like that will be in the game
from that episode onward which doesn't
mean too much but it does mean that the
new stuff from the new updates is in
there such as the new building tools and
the bobsled coaster though I most likely
won't actually be able to get a bobsled
in this car in this park since there
just isn't any room for it really which
is one of the things which I do want to
say very quickly as well I got many many
comments giving me feedback on what sort
of coaster people want to have in the
park which is really awesome i love i
think most of the votes are actually
towards a girl our eurofighter which i
might do but i am not quite sure there
were also some people who wanted me to
get a winged coaster in but
really the main problem that i have with
trying to figure out what sort of
coaster i want to have is that the only
room that i still have left in this park
is tucked away in the bottom left corner
and it really isn't that much room so i
really doubt if i can actually get a
wing coaster in there so i probably
won't other were some other ideas as
well which i completely forgot about i
think but so far it's i think the
Eurofighter is the most popular choice
my own choice would have actually been
to try a arrow coaster in there since it
seems like I've got a bit of a
rectangular space left and in order to
fill that as well as the fact that the
space is not that large I figured a
arrow mega looper could actually be a
thing as well but then again it's
probably something that I'm just gonna
mess with and see what works best in
that position it's really hard for me
and I'm quite sorry about that it's
really hard for me to take suggestions
and I just implement them no matter what
since sometimes things just don't work
out in your Park and to be quite honest
sometimes i just also don't really have
any inspiration or any feel for building
a particular kind of ride i am at the
moment I'm still sort of tossing it
between the Eurofighter and the mega
looper idea so that's something that I
want to get in there to actually talk
about what is relevant in this video
which I haven't been doing I'm bit sorry
for that is that this is currently the
lockeroom station which is one of the
things which I really wanted to get done
in hindsight I'm not too happy about it
kind of went into it figuring that I
could build a alpine station much like
the ones that are very popular in roller
coaster cone 3 with a lot of woodwork in
there but it didn't turn out to be quite
as nice as I was hoping to an isometric
view I do think it still looks all right
but in in 3d view it is just terrible
and it doesn't really have the density
or detailed woodwork and that makes such
a building look really good which is
honestly one of the issues that I do
still have if i wanna make buildings
like this in pike text you can get a
general sense of the shape of buildings
and a general design very much right
simp architect but when it comes to
buildings that just need those very
small details actually make them look
like what they're supposed to be which i
think the Alpine buildings with a lot of
woodwork on an example of it just
doesn't work too well yet there is
probably going to be an Alpine set in
some sort of future for this game it's a
pretty popular theme but so far it's
it's pretty hard to actually do it and
I'd like to say that I tried for this
station but sort of field and it's not
too bad but you can kind of notice that
i spammed a lot of trees in front of it
which is sort of the standard sort of
procedure if you have an ugly building
just get some trees in front of it and
it'll look sort of good automatically
that's um I kind of I don't know of
anybody anybody else is interested in
that sort of stuff but when architects
like pre-render their buildings to show
off how it looks sometimes they'll just
spam loads of trees in front of it or
even so many planters and balconies and
have a lot of green and that's basically
how you can sell that people are trying
to sort of mask the fact that the
building didn't quite turn out as good
looking as it could have been usually
that is and it's what I usually do to
cover up my less good buildings so
that's a bit of confession about that
and a tip if you ever have a building
anything it's ugly but you don't want to
remove it just place a lot of foliage in
it I mean can pull in it around it and
it's gonna be alright eventually or at
least it's not going to look too bad
that being said I'm not too much going
to worry about it since in the end I
don't want to make this park being
filmed or photographed in 3d look I
might do a couple of 3d shots but it's
not my main sort of thing which is
religious because I believe that since
this game is originally isometric and
has very simple graphics and it's sort
of an ode to the old roller coaster
tycoon games especially in the way that
it looks it just looks best in isometric
view and when you go into 3d view you
kind of delete that entire sense of
fantasy that
game has which is something that I
wouldn't like to break it's when you
turn on 3d it becomes less like a
fantasy less like a nice like a game
reality and more like a real life
simulation which I don't think parks act
is or should be it's I like the graphics
for what they are but it's definitely
not to be played like roller coaster in
three years or at least that's my view
on it which is why I might do some povs
just will help it and because they are
so popular and final video that I'm
going to make for this park but the main
focus will really just be an isometric
view which is I guess just more of a
personal opinion and that I think it
looks better but um yeah that's that I
will make a final video but just an
isometric view and going over the
attractions and having a POV here and
there but anyway I'm out of time for
this episode so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next episode and hopefully that is
otherwise have a good one